DC versus marble it's a battle as old as
Star Wars versus Star Trek or ballistic
X versus ever
today we'll be pitting the strongest
heroes from each sides films against
each other
treating their movies like their real
video evidence making physicists study
the clips to get hard numbers on their
speed and strength then having them
compete in a challenge of our own design
to settle which team is the most
powerful this is power levels our
competitors are a who's who of Opie
protagonists from the world of DC
Superman and Wonder Woman and from the
MCU Captain Marvel and Thor for our
challenges we'll have to really race
around the earth so you could take the
full force of a star and finally face
off in a good old-fashioned tug-of-war
most points at the end of all three is
crowned the most powerful ready let's go
we'll start with a quick grease around
the world each character will circle
Earth's 25 thousand mile equator before
tagging in their partner to do the same
fastest total time wins to calculate
their top speed well analyze objects in
the background of their fastest clips by
estimating the object size we can
measure how much distance each hero can
cover in a given time and get their
velocity here we can see Superman being
chased down by an ICBM and Batman V
Superman giving him a speed of at least
ten thousand eight hundred miles per
hour Wonder Woman can deflect bullets
shot from an ar-15 in this scene from
Justice League by estimating her
shoulder dimensions and how far she
moves relative to the bullets he plays
her speed at 1125 miles per hour
meanwhile in the marvel burst
we're not letting Thor use the Bifrost
to teleport but in this shot from his
first movie he physically flies down
Asgard's Rainbow Road we used a few
different scenes of people standing on
the bridge to get a speed of 573 miles
per hour and at the end of Captain
Marvel's first film she keeps pace with
a scroll ship as it jumps to Lightspeed
which means Carol goes flying at 670
million miles per hour whoa as
impressive as that is she's still got a
teammate to carry though word
forty three and a half hours to circle
the earth getting team Marvel a total of
forty three and a half hours plus 0.1
seconds Thor get it together man blowing
this Wonder Woman Superman finished
their laps in twenty two and two point
three hours respectively giving them a
combined time of twenty four point three
hours and the point for challenge number
one for our next challenge they'll have
to in the words of the immortal Dinklage
take the full force of a star to measure
who can soak up the most punishment
Superman's best hit is when he survives
a close-range explosion from a modern
nuclear bomb assuming he absorbs even a
10% fraction of the nukes total energy
he'll have at least a 100 tera Joule
energy capacity for Wonder Woman it's
when she takes a full blast of
Doomsday's eye laser for about three
seconds
assuming Doomsday's lasers have the same
energy of Superman's we can look at this
scene from the run-up to Zod's murder
watch as they melt a 5-foot steel beam
in about 75 milliseconds this implies
Wonder Woman can absorb at least 240
million joules but now it's Marvel's
time to shine Darla stands the energy of
a neutron star and Avengers infinity war
we can estimate the total power radiated
using the Stefan Boltzmann equation for
calculating the power radiated from a
heated body naturally and we can assume
the average size and temperature of
visible neutron stars
this gives Thor an energy absorption
capacity of at least three times ten to
the 26 joules that's like getting hit
with two nuclear bombs at the same time
and yet that's nothing compared to his
teammates accelerating any object with
mass to the speed of light takes an
infinite amount of energy so if Captain
Marvel can accelerate to Lightspeed her
body can absorb an infinite amount as
well braking the challenge and possibly
the MCU Marvel absolutely crushes DC in
this challenge tying up the score at one
point apiece now it's time for a tug of
war in almost all cases our competitors
biggest feats of strength we're using
weapons a no-no in tug of war or with a
pushing or punching motion instead of a
pull so we're gonna make it a little
easier on ourselves and assume each hero
can push and pull with equal strength
because give us a break check out this
shot of Superman punching doomsday as
they fall back to earth
well estimate Doomsday's mass is roughly
the same as a small elephant then
his change in momentum after he's hit
Superman imparts a 10 million newton
punch where roughly the thrust of a
space shuttle booster engine for Wonder
Woman she overhead presses a British
mark for tank that weighs 32 tons this
means she can lift with the force of two
hundred and eighty four thousand
Newton's or about the same thrust as a
747 engine Thor's largest feat of
physical strength of his own body no
hammers allowed is when he knocks the
Hulk across the arena on Sekar look
ahead specs online the Hulk weighs an
estimated 1400 pounds which means Thor
has 111 thousand two hundred Newton's of
force at his disposal for Captain Marvel
almost all her strength scenes involve
her energy blast her best show of
strength with her body is when she kicks
keroth across a room the average person
can punch about 75% as hard as they can
kick so 75% of the force exerted here
gives us a result of 11,000 187 Newtons
fun fact we asked our scientists how
harder heroes could pelvic thrust
because we are children and it turns out
an air-hump is anywhere from 0.1 to 1
percent the force of a punch
meaning Superman's hips generate at a
minimum twice as much as it takes to
break bones and it maximum somewhere
around the thrust of an f-22 Raptor
engine oh my god Lois I'm so sorry
anyway after adding the totals together
DC crushes Marvel with ten million eight
hundred ninety four thousand Newton's
two Marvel's poultry one hundred twenty
two thousand three hundred eighty-seven
giving them point number three and the
overall wit oh I can feel the Marvel
fanboy rage from here
see can we give the MCU one more chance
to even up the score how about we see
which team would do the best at knocking
a comet off a collision course with
earth no restrictions on weapons or
energy blasts cool cool let's pick a
well-known orbiting object like Halley's
Comet and let's say the best time and
place to disrupt it would be when it's
closest to the Sun the heroes will try
to add as much force as possible to
knock it off its path and out of the
solar system so once again we'll look
for each character's greatest on-screen
feat of strength but now we can take all
their powers into account not just
punches and kicks for Captain Marvel her
strongest move becomes when she smashes
through the Kree warship at the end of
her solo outing zooming the ship has
something like five inch thick steel
walls her max force skyrockets to about
4 million Newtons
well let's stop here for a second we
don't want to waste your time it would
take billions of joules to push Halley's
comet out of orbit none of our heroes
show off anything close to that power on
screen even all four of their strongest
blows combined wouldn't move it off a
collision course so if one day we find
out a comet is heading straight towards
the Earth
maybe call I don't know meteor man
doesn't matter or screwed and since
neither team is strong enough to
complete the challenge the final plank
goes to no one you get nothing you all
lose good day sir
sorry carried away there for a sec turns
out DC is still the overall winner and
earns the title of most powerful duo
congratulations gods you beat the MCU
everywhere but the box office if you
don't like it do bad that's where the
data leaves us and the data doesn't care
about your feelings
we care about you let us know you'd like
to see you square off and you could see
them here in the next episode power
levels
[Music]
you